>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Eric Deggans: How you doing?
Thanks so much for joining us here.
We really appreciate it.
As was said, my name's Eric
Deggans, and I'm TV critic
for National Public Radio.
So of course I should
be talking to an author.
Actually, I've written a lot about
race in media and have also --
I interviewed Taraji P.
Henson for [inaudible]
so we got a little
bit in common here.
So our esteemed guest, the daughter
of a NASA scientist
and English professor?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Yeah.
>> Eric Deggans: Virginia native.
You worked in investment banking?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: That
was my first job out of school.
>> Eric Deggans: Wow.
And also had a magazine
for expats in Mexico.
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Mexico.
>> Eric Deggans: Inside Mexico?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Yeah.
>> Eric Deggans: Started working
on Hidden Figures in 2010.
Wow. And became a New York
Times number one bestseller,
spawned a movie that
was Oscar nominated.
Margo Lee Shetterly, everyone.
[ Applause ]
So I heard that you gave an
amazing speech last night
where you talked a little bit
about Charlottesville and race.
Could you give us just a little
taste of what you talked about there
and how it compares to what
you talk about in the book.
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Yeah.
The thing that we talked a little
bit about what I started out doing,
which was working in
investment banking out of school.
And really when I was growing
up, that seemed like progress
in the future and very
protagonist way --
life or career to have,
like very powerful.
And history for me, it was
something that always felt --
I think as an African American,
always so heavy and connected
to this past, which is usually
taught in schools as slavery,
Martin Luther King, and of course
now there's Obama, this very long
but extremely narrow arc of history.
And so during the course of writing
Hidden Figures, what I really came
to understand was how powerful
it is to be able to tell a story
and to write a story and
to tell your own story
and to be the protagonist
in your own story as opposed
to telling a story
where you are kind
of the passive recipient of history.
And so I live in Charlottesville,
Virginia.
I went to the University of
Virginia, but recently moved there.
And this entire issue of the statues
and then the white
supremacist marches,
all of that stuff has been
happening since I've moved there,
and I think for me we're
very focused on the presence
of the statues and the
meaning of the statues,
what they have come to symbolize.
But I think part of the issue
also is that the statues,
they also represent an
absence of a counter narrative,
that there is the slavery narrative.
There are these confederate
statues, but in terms of a diversity
and a richness of African American
stories, there are very few
and there are very few in which
African Americans are protagonists.
And these stories in which you are
allowed to be a protagonist matter.
I mean, each of us is the
protagonist in our own life.
We see ourselves as
people with agency,
and I think that's why we love
stories about super heroes and kings
and -- these stories
make us feel powerful.
And so I think that it is really --
it is about the presence of
the apartheid and the presence
of the racial terror and slavery,
but it's also about the absence
of the counter narrative.
I really see that one of
the jobs of bringing --
bridging some of these divides
is bringing forward these stories
that have always been there.
The people have been there.
The history is there.
The stories are what
we need to tell now.
>> Eric Deggans: Right.
Well, for people who may have been
under a rock for the last year
or so, Hidden Figures, this
amazing book about these black women
who served as human computers
working for both the agency before
that preceded NASA and for NASA,
crunching all of this complex math,
these complex numbers that were used
first to develop the aerodynamics
for planes and then later to --
for space flight and the moon shot.
Now I saw in the book you said
this isn't hidden history,
it's unseen history.
And I know you say everybody
asks you why don't we know this?
But I'm going to ask you,
why don't we know this?
And why is it unseen?
Are we afraid to look at it?
Are we -- were we too
busy lionizing NASA
and John Glenn and people like that?
Why was it unseen?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: I think the
primary reason why this history has
been unseen is because
this work was women's work,
and that not just at NASA.
So there was this [inaudible]
of African American women
working at NASA Langley.
They were part of a much
larger cohort of women
from all backgrounds
doing the work at all
of the different NASA centers.
There were women computers
working in the Army and the Navy.
They were working at Bell Labs,
which many of you may know
is the precursor to AT&T
and basically founded the
communications revolution,
cell phones and things like that.
Virtually everywhere you
found technological progress
that required number crunching and
reduction of data, there were women.
There were rooms full of women kind
of like a living Excel
spreadsheet doing math, and I --
this work it was considered
sub professional work.
It was very necessary, but literally
the women at NASA were classified
as sub professionals which meant
they were above clerical employees.
They were not as high in
the hierarchy as the men
who were engineers who were
considered professional employees.
And so I think that that's a large
reason why this work was invisible.
They were kind of the equivalent
of our computers sitting
on our desks doing the work
today and yet without them,
all of these advances would
not have been possible.
>> Eric Deggans: Now I'm interested
in how you decided to focus on this
because I know, of course, you
were surrounded by these people
when you were growing up, and I've
done panels where I talk to people
and they go, "Well, I had this
idea and then I made it a reality
by doing X, Y and Z," and I
think to myself, wait a minute.
I want to hear about how you had the
idea because that to me is the key,
deciding -- I mean there
were plenty of other people
who grew up around these people.
In your neighborhood
when you were growing up,
I'm sure everybody
knew these stories.
What made you decide
this was worth a book?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Well,
I've told this story before.
It's interesting.
The moment -- there's a very
specific moment when Hidden Figures,
what would become Hidden
Figures came into existence.
And interestingly, it
came out of a moment
between the two most
important men in my life,
my father and my husband.
And so my husband and I
had gone back to Hampton,
and we were visiting my parents
for Christmas seven years ago now.
And we had run into a woman who
had worked at NASA many years
as a computer, and that sort
of sparked this conversation
of my Dad sort of going into this
speech about what she had done
and the other women and
Katherine Johnson who --
she calculated the launch
window for the astronauts.
It was a very casual way.
>> Eric Deggans: You're
like wait a minute,
that moment where the
needle slips off the record.
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: But
I didn't have that moment.
I didn't hear the needle slip off
the record because I had heard a lot
of those stories before,
and I had grown up there,
and I had known these
women but had known them
as my parents' colleagues
and friends.
But the needle definitely slipped
off the record for my husband
who is not from Hampton
and was like wait a minute.
Can you please replay that for me?
And why haven't I heard
that story before?
And so for me it was a moment
of looking at the community,
the people, NASA, this very
extraordinary kind of place
that I had grown up and that was
also extremely normal and ordinary
but looking -- being able to see
past what was so normal to me
and say wow, that is
pretty remarkable.
>> Eric Deggans: Yeah,
and what's amazing to me
about the book is the level
of detail that you're able
to bring forth about
these people's lives.
I mean, I feel like when Dorothy
Vaughn is walking to teach
at a high school, I'm walking right
along with her because you're able
to describe what that
journey was like.
How did you get that
level of detail?
How did find the research to
say what the place smelled like
or what landmarks she passed when
she was walking to that high school?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Doing
the research, I loved it.
I mean, I loved it.
And I really -- the kind of book
that I wanted to write was the kind
of book that I loved reading,
which is really detailed narrative
nonfiction where you are so immersed
in this dream and this life
that you lose yourself.
You go into this time machine.
And so I -- I mean, the sources --
there were so many
different kinds of sources.
First of all, interviews
with people.
Katherine Johnson who just turned
99 years old really amazing.
I was very fortunate --
>> Eric Deggans: Taraji P. Henson.
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Yes.
>> Eric Deggans: You all
that didn't read the book.
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: So I got
to spend a lot of time with her
and talk to her not just about
her life but also Dorothy Vaughn,
for example, and the
relationship between the --
Dorothy Vaughn and the
women who worked for her.
There were employee
newsletters starting in 1942
for the Langley Research Center,
which was called the Langley
Aeronautical Laboratory back then.
Black newspapers, amazing source
of information, the description
of Mary Jackson's wedding dress
in the book came from an article
in the Norfolk Journal and Guide.
I mean, the level of detail
in the black newspapers.
>> Eric Deggans: Talk about
telling our own story.
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Yeah.
It is amazing, absolutely
extraordinary.
The NASA history office
and the Langley Research Center
has done a spectacular job
in preserving wind tunnel records,
research reports, phone books,
seating charts, photos of offices
and work groups, teams of people.
It was -- so I really -- I
loved that part of it, and I --
if I didn't have to
eventually turn in a book,
I probably would still
be doing that research.
>> Eric Deggans: Now I
heard that you already --
you sold the rights
to this to be made
into a movie while
you were writing it?
Man, I'm scared of you.
I am scared of you.
How'd you convince somebody
to buy the movie rights
to a book you hadn't even
finished writing yet?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Or that I
hadn't actually even started writing
is the --
>> Eric Deggans: I want her agent.
Who's your agent?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Yeah.
I will tell you I have a
very good literary agent.
Her name is McKenzie Brady
Watson, young, very smart.
>> Eric Deggans: Excuse me.
>> Margot Lee Shetterly:
And she was the one
who represented my book proposal
and sold it to Harper Collins,
and then she was the one who
basically facilitated the getting it
into the hands of Donna
Gigliotto, who is the Producer
for Hidden Figures,
and Donna read it,
and she immediately felt a
sense of mission, I think.
She really made her job
championing this story as a movie.
She made it her mission, and
it -- it is not a usual or --
it was sort of a lightning strike
set of circumstances that happened
with the book and the movie.
>> Eric Deggans: Wow.
Well, now what I love about the book
in addition to all the great detail
that we get about these wonderful
women is that you're able to talk
about so many different
things within that narrative.
One example is the way in which
we've always had these periods
where there's been progress on
Civil Rights in America often
because America is threatened.
World War I, World War II the
Cold War, and then these periods
of backlash where black
soldiers are coming back
from the war and they get beat up.
This attempt to put
people back in their place.
Talk a little bit about how those
themes work in Hidden Figures
and why it was so important to
make sure that we had a sense
of this sweep of history
in that way.
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Yeah,
I think again a lot of it came
from my interest and my preference
for these epic narratives,
and I wanted that these women
had that epic narrative.
So it wasn't enough to
either to show their lives
or simply to show the history.
I wanted their lives directly
connected to the sweep of history.
And the thing about these women
is that they in so many ways,
their lives were connected to
the big history and not just
for them working at NASA starting
in World War II, but for example,
Katherine Johnson was one
of three black students
to integrate the graduate
schools in West Virginia.
Dorothy Vaughn worked at --
as a math teacher before
she went to NASA.
She worked at a school in Farmville,
Virginia that filed a lawsuit
that was eventually incorporated
into the Brown versus Board
of Education suit, and that school
system was shut down by the state
of Virginia rather than comply with
the board decision and integrate.
So it was -- it really was
fascinating to me to look
at these sweeps of history and
to see how this opening for all
of these women happened during
World War II and because of the need
for labor and because
of the external threat.
And that we would see these
periods of backlash, for example,
when after Brown -- when
Virginia closed its schools.
So I wanted to understand how the
big picture circumstances affected
the individual lives of these people
and how they responded
to those circumstances.
>> Eric Deggans: Yeah, yeah.
I also love this idea of looking
at, for example, during the cold war
when all of these countries
were fighting off their colonial
oppressors and the pressure that it
brought in America to show that hey,
we're not really that bad.
Hey, we'll strike down segregation.
Please join us instead of
going with the communists,
India or Liberia or Cuba.
And you were able to also show how
that fit into their stories, too,
which I thought was amazing.
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Yeah,
I mean this time of Sputnik --
1957 when the Soviets put
Sputnik, their satellite into space
that really kind of kicked off the
space race version of the cold war,
that was a fascinating time.
I mean, this was a
time of McCarthyism.
It's the time of the Sputnik
obviously, the excitement of going
into space, the fear of -- that
maybe the Russians are spying on us.
It's the time that Little
Rock happened in 1957.
So one of the most -- I mean, just
unbelievable documents that I found
that I put in the book that sort
of connected those two things is
that the Russians would
always publish a time table
of where the Sputnik satellite
was overflying during its sort
of orbit around the earth.
And so I found this Washington
Post article that showed
that the Russians published
when it was flying
over Little Rock, Arkansas.
So very direct connections
between the domestic turmoil
and the United States and this
international global battle
between the United States
and the Soviet Union.
>> Eric Deggans: And this idea
that because of segregation
and because people were oppressed
that America was holding
itself back.
Like maybe one reason the
Russians got Sputnik up earlier is
because they gave women more agency
as engineers in the Soviet Union.
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Yeah.
There were many, many
more female engineers
in engineering school there than
there were here in the United States
where women were still having
problems even getting admitted
to engineering programs.
So yeah, no, I mean, I
think one of the things
that was very clear during the
research into Hidden Figures is
that the story is so important.
The stories that we tell ourselves,
the stories that we disseminate
inside the country outside
of the country, all of these
things affected the decisions
that people made in a very real
way, and the government was involved
in shaping those stories both
internally and externally.
>> Eric Deggans: Now your book
covers a wide swath of history.
It starts in 1943, comes all the way
through to the end
of the space program.
Hidden Figures, the
movie, doesn't do that.
Now, I went through the whole
book looking for Kevin Costner.
I didn't see no Kevin Costner.
So -- and I know that you said
that you enjoyed the movie,
and you didn't have a problem
with it, but were you surprised
at how they chose to tell the story
because it seems like they kind
of conflated a lot of things
and kind of crunched a lot
of circumstances together to make
the narrative more compelling.
>> Margot Lee Shetterly:
Yeah, I mean,
it was a really interesting
experience
of this whole Hidden Figures theme.
While I was writing my first
book, learning how to do that --
>> Eric Deggans: Your first book.
Her first book.
Oh my God.
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: I was
also getting a crash course
in what it takes to adapt a book
for film and how you tell a story
through film and how
you tell a story --
sort of the difference between
fact and truth so there are a lot
of facts that are conflated in the
movie, but what I really appreciated
about the final product of the
movie is that it's very true.
It's very true to the
nature of the women.
It is very true to
the circumstances.
It's very true to NASA and
that sense of what it was
like during those early days of the
space race, but it was really hard
for me because first of all, I
wrote this book from 1943 to 1969.
I was like why can't you make a
movie that goes from 1943 to 1969.
>> Eric Deggans: Or TV
show says the TV critic.
>> Margot Lee Shetterly:
Yeah, I mean, that was hard.
I think it was very
much the right decision
to make a compact narrative focused
around this very dramatic moment
in Katherine Johnson's life
where she calculates the
trajectory for John Glenn's flight.
And it was difficult to see certain
elements of the story shifted
from one character to the other
or see things that were created
like I'm sure anyone who has seen
the movie you probably did figure
this out, but yes, there was
no Kevin Costner character
who sledge hammered the colored
sign in Langley, but it's sort of --
>> Eric Deggans: I was
looking -- I was in the index.
Where's the --
>> Margot Lee Shetterly:
But so it was --
there were moments when I
struggled with some of the decisions
and there were moments --
>> Eric Deggans: One of the things
that struck me, for example,
was that in you book you say
that they basically ended
segregation in [inaudible] in 1958?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Yeah, so
basically, yeah when [crosstalk] --
>> Eric Deggans: So the time that
they're portraying in the movie
where there still seems
to be segregation,
they had already stopped that?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Yes.
>> Eric Deggans: So does the --
yeah, the department wasn't
segregated during the time
that the movie shoes.
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Exactly,
but in order to bring together
these two very dramatic things
which is John Glenn's orbital flight
and Katherine Johnson doing
the calculations and the end
of segregation, they were
conflated in terms of timeline.
>> Eric Deggans: Was
there ever a moment
when they had to break that to you?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly:
Well you know what?
I have to say I know a lot of
people who have written books
and have them made into movies
have different opinions,
but I had a very positive experience
with this, and the producer,
in particular Donna Gigliotti
who was the producer,
really kept me in the loop.
Every once in a while it's like 3
o'clock in the morning and I'd be
up working to try and finish
this draft so I can turn it in
and then the script would pop up
like latest version of the script.
And so they really did
an amazing job, I think,
of keeping me in the loop,
of honoring my suggestions,
really listening to me and doing
all they could to understand
and preserve the authenticity of the
story, which I was very happy with.
>> Eric Deggans: Right.
So the movie comes out,
and it's very successful.
I think it was the highest grossing
movie amongst all the movies
that were nominated for best
picture the year that it came out.
Your book was a New
York Times bestseller,
and then a year later we have
white supremacists marching
through Virginia who feel
like they've been supported
by the President of
the United States.
What do you think?
I mean, on the one hand, there's
a sense that this story comes out
and people are so hungry for this
history and they are so worried
about how people have been oppressed
and how this history has been
oppressed and then a year later,
we have people who
would be right at home
with the birds upholding white
supremacy marching down the middle
of a street in the
town that you live in.
What do you think of that?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: I mean,
this is I think -- this is America.
I think a lot of -- there's
been a lot of commentary
after Charlottesville that the
town and the state and the country
that this is not who we are.
It is who we are.
I mean, America is
a complicated place.
>> Eric Deggans: You
can clap for that.
Go ahead.
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: But what
I mean is it's a complicated place.
Its been a complicated
place from the beginning.
And we have some of the most admired
and beautiful and worthy ideals.
I mean, we hold these truths
to be self evident that all men
and people are created equal.
I mean, this is something that we
navigate by and that we believe
in here fundamentally, and we are
always at war with the ideal that --
and the reality of the
implementation and that is --
when I say this is
America, that struggle is --
that is the struggle
that we're always facing.
And so it is -- I think
that we are --
this is a part of that struggle
for living up to those ideals
and saying what does it take to
really support and allow everyone
into those ideals and believing
in those ideals, doing what we can
to enforce them and to spread them.
And I -- for me, I live 12
minutes driving from Monticello,
and I think Monticello,
it's a fascinating place.
Thomas Jefferson was an absolutely
riveting person who owned people,
humans, something that today we find
objectionable and who wrote some
of the most amazing and
insightful and beautiful words
about the nature of human freedom.
And so that dichotomy is -- that
is sort of the core, I think,
in a lot of ways that struggle of
America, and I think particularly
for me anyway as an
African American,
really trying to unite
those two things
to say I both acknowledge the
circumstances of slavery in the past
and all of the heaviness that
comes with that, and I also embrace
and love the beautiful parts
of those ideals of our country
and the best of our country.
So it's complicated.
Every -- humans are complicated,
and this is a complicated place,
but I -- I think the fact that we
are living in a moment that it feels
like we're living in
the history right now.
It's terrifying.
It's fascinating.
It's all these things at the same
time, and I think it's a moment
where the American
ideals are calling to us,
and it's sort of like saying
can we take these from ideals
to putting them into practice
in our every day lives?
>> Eric Deggans: Now we are
going to take a few questions.
So I'm going to ask if you have
a question to line up at one
of these two mics, and I will
point to you, and I will ask you
to say your question and
please make it a question.
Okay? Please.
I always feel like the
stories of black folks
and especially black
women in the south get
at that what you just
talked about so effectively.
The wonderful things about our
country and also the things
that we struggle with, the duality
of all these popular figures.
We live that as black folks
in the south, do you think?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly:
You know what?
I am a native Virginian.
I am a native of the south.
I love the south.
The south is a complicated place.
I think people from -- a lot of
these issues that exist everywhere
in America are maybe closer
to the surface in the south.
So I do -- and southerners have a --
I guess the reputation of
being great lovers of history.
And I think this embracing even
the hard things like really trying
to face those hard things and
make them also part of who we are
as a country and who
we are as individuals
and maybe it's the individual --
I think for me like trying to do
that work as an individual
and embrace all
of those things even the
painful things is part
of my heritage as an American.
I think within me that's
sort of like the fusing
of all these -- the conflict.
I want those things to
be able to coexist even
as they are difficult things.
>> Eric Deggans: Yeah.
All right.
Let's start over here if you
could just tell us your name
and your question.
>> Hello. My name is
Debbie Greenberg.
I loved your movie.
It gave me insight into my uncle
and cousins who grew up in Hampton.
He worked at Langley as well.
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Oh wow.
>> [Inaudible] back in that era.
Now I understand.
Thank you.
>> Eric Deggans: You
should read the book.
There's more about it there.
>> My question to you as somebody
who grew up there just a few years
after what you portray, what
was the cultural environment,
the racial environment, the
interfaith environment and how has
that influenced you
and your outlook?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: I
consider myself as having grown
up in a very -- in a
very interesting place
and a very wonderful time.
So until I started doing
the research for this book,
I didn't realize just how close
I was to kind of the tail end
of this period of desegregation
of the schools in Virginia
because Virginia really dragged
its feet for a long time.
But when I went to school, I
went to integrated schools.
Black kids and white kids.
There were actually a lot of
Vietnamese people who lived
in the community so
we were heavily --
as you know, maybe Hampton runs
the very heavily military area,
defense industry.
So in addition to NASA,
there are any number of Army,
Navy bases, Air Force base.
So it really does get
a lot of people
from a lot of different places.
And I think there was
a period that was --
the space thing had just happened.
People were still very optimistic
about that and so I feel like I grew
up in what to me was like sort of
still riding a lot of the optimism
for progress and change from
the Civil Rights Movement
from the space race there in
Hampton, and I went to a very kind
of normal -- I don't know,
American normal whatever that is
in the popular imagination public
school with kids from a lot
of different backgrounds,
socioeconomic backgrounds.
I mean, I think this is something
that has changed since I was
in school, that I went to
school with kids who were
on public assistance,
and I went to school
with kids whose parents
were quite affluent.
And I think growing up with this
very diverse and not just ethnicity,
but I means in terms of economics,
nationality even was
a real privilege.
And so I feel very, very
fortunate to have gone
to the Hampton Public
Schools, got a great education
and very much love my hometown.
>> Eric Deggans: Over here.
Your name and your question.
>> Hi. I'm Katie Dansler,
and I was wondering
if you considered writing sort of a
follow up, maybe following the story
up at Dwight or the Mercury 13?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Yes.
So the Mercury 13 was a group of
women who were being recruited
with the idea that they could also
be part of the astronaut core,
and Ed Dwight is an African American
who was also recruited
into the astronaut core.
Those are amazing stories.
I mean, the thing about
Hidden Figures is that I --
there were so many
different fascinating stories
and people involved.
Those are, I think, somebody
-- those are very worthy.
I'm actually working on a next book
that doesn't have to do with NASA,
but those -- I spend so much time
even now reading about people
who were in some way
involved with this spine
of the Hidden Figures story.
So I don't have those plans, but I
mean, I think that those are stories
that we definitely
could [crosstalk].
>> Eric Deggans: Perhaps
you could write that book,
and you do mention Ed in the book.
Your name and your story
-- and your question.
>> Hello. My name is Steven.
Excuse me, I'm a little
nervous, Thomas.
I saw the movie, and it was
in an audience like this,
diverse like this,
predominantly white.
But when it was over, people
applauded and people were crying.
My wife was crying.
The white man next
to her was crying.
The Asian woman next
to him was crying,
and I was wondering what
you felt about what evoked
that deep emotion, tears of joy?
Tears of hope?
Tears of sadness?
What's your thinking on the
emotional impact of that story?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly:
That is a great question.
I've seen the movie like ten
times in different settings,
very different settings,
and it has been the same.
I've seen in Hampton where
everybody knows the people.
I've seen it in -- I mean, just
with the people who made the movie.
I mean, just so many different
settings, and it has been that.
I think that it is --
there are these ideals.
There are these things that we
want to believe about who we are,
about who we can be and
I think that maybe what
that movie does is it shows us
an instance of closing the gap
between who we are when we fall
short and who we are when we stand
up and go up to our highest
level, and it's optimistic.
It doesn't shy away from
the difficult things,
but it doesn't take away the hope.
And you need to look the difficult
things squarely in the eye,
but you can never take
away the hope,
and you can't deny the progress.
Even in a moment like
now when people --
we're saying where there are many
challenges facing this country.
Well, there have always been
We have made a lot of progress,
and I feel like we need to --
we need to acknowledge that
and even as we look squarely
at very difficult things,
we're humans.
We need hope.
We need happy stories to get up in
the morning and give us meaning,
and I think that is maybe it.
It shows the hard things.
We have to see those things.
We have to acknowledge them,
but we need the hope as well,
and it's a very hopeful movie,
and it's a movie about people
who love what they're doing and who
-- for whom that becomes a bond.
They come from all these
different backgrounds,
but these people are passionate
about the space program and numbers
and math, and that is very
true to who these people are.
And it enabled them to
transcend and become very close,
and I think that's
also very positive.
>> Keep hope alive.
Thank you very much.
>> Eric Deggans: Your
name and your question.
>> My name's Indola
Latte [assumed spelling].
I wrote down my question
because I'm nervous too, Thomas.
At the beginning of this talk,
you talked about how history
was not hidden but unseen
and the book you wrote and the
movie that was produced was one way
of making this story seen and
visible to much of the American
and international public.
What are other ways you see unseen
or counter narratives
being brought to light?
And how do you think the awareness
of these stories will have an effect
on the actions that we as America
take and on the global community?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: When I --
growing up, I always thought of
history as the history of politics
and presidents and -- I mean, this
sort of very big picture history,
but history is really what
all of us, each of us,
does and history is
about communities.
It's about people and how our
lives fit into the great course
of human events, and
I think that the --
maybe sort of in the same way that
I think science is always seen
as the great individual
scientist, Einstein and all
of these great people who have
been mostly men in the past,
but we don't see that how much
of that scientific progress
and work is based on the teamwork
and people coming together
to create something,
a great, a giant leap.
I think in the same way we see these
great individuals and we don't look
at the people around us,
and I think that's --
I mean, that sounds really
simplistic, but I think just looking
at the people around us,
grandparents, people who live
down the street, why is this moment
here and its been there for so long
and how did it get there?
I mean, asking these questions
about things in our surroundings
and saying that we're going to
start looking at the history
from the ground up as opposed to
the history from the top down.
I mean, I love those stories
because I think those are sort
of very human level stories,
and I think that those --
that very human level
view of why things --
why things happen is something
people are really hungry for.
I was dying to go and see the
presentation of J.D. Vance
who I think is also writing about
people in our country from a point
of view that we don't always get
and that people are hungry for.
And I think there's a
lot of similar energy
between why people are very
interested in hidden figures
and very interested in [inaudible],
and I think maybe people see
that as a contradiction, but I think
there's quite a lot of similarity
between what people are looking for.
So I think maybe looking from the
bottom up as opposed to the top
down in terms of history
is a great start.
>> Eric Deggans: Okay.
This will be our last
question from the field.
So better be good.
Just saying.
>> [Inaudible] be the last question.
My name is Allen Weinstein.
Not quite Einstein, but --
>> Eric Deggans: Well now
you're really raising the bar.
>> But in my own way, I like
to think I made a contribution
to the emergence of
computer technology
in science in my field particular.
So I'd like to thank you for your
contribution from the vantage point
of a white male, not an
African American female.
But what I actually [inaudible] my
question is how did the book differ
from the movie in any
significant way?
And what was your role in
that if it was a difference
between the book and the movie?
What was your role
in that difference?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: So --
well the biggest difference
between the book and the movie
as the book starts in
1943 and ends in 1969,
and the movie is just a sliver,
basically takes place from 1957
to 1962 and because of that as we
talked about a lot of the timelines
and things were conflated.
So I was a consultant on the movie.
They would ask me questions.
I would give them a lot of research.
And -- but one -- just sort of
to speak a little bit to the math
and the computer part
of it, so the book --
NASA is an engineering organization.
A lot of this was about building
planes and building spaceships,
and the book Hidden Figures
is very much about that.
But because Katherine
Johnson as a mathematician
in that whole hierarchy
was the central character,
they really created a plot in
the movie that hinged on math
and her viewpoint, it was really --
it was just something that
I didn't even really learn
until after the movie was produced
and had all these questions
about how this particular part
of the script had come together,
but they made this very interesting
decision to really make it a movie
about math as opposed to
about the engineering,
which the book is a lot
more about engineering
than the minutia of the math.
>> Eric Deggans: Of the math,
yeah, yeah, and about their lives.
I mean, you --
>> Margot Lee Shetterly:
And about their lives.
>> Eric Deggans: You detail
their lives a lot more
than the specific projects
that they worked on.
I wanted to ask you
real quickly to talk
about the human computer
project that you're working on.
This is something you have
continued past the life of the book.
Can you talk a little bit
about what you're doing there
and how its succeeded since the
book and the movie have come out?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: So yeah,
the human computer project --
essentially what I was so surprised
to discover during the research
for Hidden Figures is how many
women were involved in computing
as I talked about before
not just at NASA,
but in all of these
other organizations,
and so this is really a way to
try and catalog all of the women
who are involved in doing this
work in the early days of computing
and really understand what kind
of work they were doing and also
to get a snapshot of women in these
fields and see if there's something
that we might learn from those
early pioneers that we can apply
to women working in
these fields today.
>> Eric Deggans: So if people want
to participate, they
can find it online?
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Yeah,
thehumancomputerproject.com
or you can reach out to me
at margotleeshetterly.com.
>> Eric Deggans: Great.
Well, thanks a lot guys.
Really appreciate your
attention, your great questions.
We ran out of time.
I got to wrap it up.
I do want to thank our esteemed
guest, Margo Lee Shetterly,
author of Hidden Figures.
I'm Eric Deggans, TV critic for NPR.
Please enjoy the rest
of the festival.
Thank you so much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.